I also find it interesting as well on
another flip side because my Auto DM
goes out and goes hey you know check out
my movies on Amazon or whatever and like
I'll get responses from all these people
around the world saying like hey I love
your movies I saw like you know this one
or that one and like all of them are
always responding saying oh I love a
more I've seen him and my my response is
like either a like a distributor owes me
a lot of money that I don't know about
or B or sorry that's so distracting uh
either a a distributor owes me a lot of
money I don't know about or B which is I
think the more likely one is you know
things are probably getting downloaded
on the internet a lot because I mean a
perfect a perfect instance of piracy is
like you know a movie I did I won't say
which one but the first like month it
was out it only like shipped like five
thousand units and then I looked at like
one of those like piracy websites and it
had something like a hundred and fifty
thousand downloads Wow and I was like
wow
like if I only have like a dollar for
every single time that that happened
it'd be you know but at least they're
watching them right not advocating
piracy but do you think that it can ever
help someone's career or that it can
help a project in some way I think
sometimes like you look at that movie um
Inc if you saw that that movie was they
actually just released it for free
online they've encouraged the piracy of
it so I think yes and no I mean
personally I'm I'm against piracy
because I think it's stealing
legitimately stealing from the filmmaker
and you know I know it's kind of weird
to say but it's like yeah it's messed up
to pirate stuff but if you're gonna
pirate stuff at least don't pirate the
indie films you know like the really
low-budget indie stuff like you know the
difference between you know one extra
DVD and and one extra download is like
somebody's rent that month possibly so
it's like you know don't I so I it's
like I feel for people because I have
like a lot of friends that like hour at
this and haven't really been doing like
well with it because of because of
piracy so I
I mean I want people to understand that
it really does hurt the filmmaker it
really does you know how do you think a
lot of people in your generation and in
slightly older feel because they've
gotten so much for free on the internet
how do they view it I mean the weird
thing about it is like you know I will
be talking to like friends like friends
from high school or like friends from
you know from childhood from like you
know elementary school or whatever
people I've known for years and years
and I'll be like hey you should check
out my new movie blah blah blah and
they'll be like they'll be like oh yeah
sure I'll just like download it or like
oh yeah watch it on like you know this
website or whatever and I'll be like
you're literally just telling me you're
gonna steal for me like would you really
come up to me and be like oh yeah I'm
gonna take $20 out of your wallet like
no but for some reason it's so like okay
amongst that like they they actually
think that it's it's become so part of
the culture that like it's fine when
it's really not so I think if there's
like a way to find to like monetize that
like you know I think if we release like
movies for free online with ads on them
or something that's at least better than
then then having them stolen but like
you know you look at like those websites
that have the movies hosted for free and
all the all this traffic's driven to
websites they're making money on those
sites because like they are selling ad
space on those sites those people are
making a lot of money off of our hard
work
you